c'est au québec qu'on élève le plus
grand nombre de porcs au pays quelques 7
millions par année une telle
concentration de bêtes devient vite un
terrain propice à la prolifération de
virus et autres pathogènes
alors comment les spécialistes de la
santé animale
arrive-t-il à contrôler et même parfois
à éradiquer de nouveaux virus le plus
souvent sans vaccin
[Musique]
février 2014 dans une ferme porcine de
la montérégie ce que les experts en
santé animale redoutait vient de se
produire
le tout nouveau virus attaque les ports
au québec
[Musique]
l'ennemi un coronavirus qui provient lui
aussi de la chine
il venait de frapper aux états unis
on savait qu'il était extrêmement
foudroyant c'est très contagieux 100%
avait pour seul affecté moureilles mais
aucun qui revenait d'un dans une
réaction initiale comme pour la covin 19
chez l'humain les vétérinaires ne
disposait d' aucun vaccin pour affronter
ce virus pourtant les experts réussiront
à le contenir et à l'éradiquer du
territoire québécois
un exploit
[Musique]
cette crise a changé la lutte aux
épidémies dans l'industrie porcine
[Musique]
l'adep c'est la diarrhée épidémique
porcine
quand cette maladie entre au québec la
province déclenché son plan d'urgence
en moins de 24 heures les fermes
porcines pas au code orange tout ronge
leurs mesures de contrôle sanitaire ce
qu'on appelle la biosécurité
quant à la ferme infectés par l'ademe
on lui et pose le code rouge on la coupe
du monde on la met en quarantaine dans
une ferme à effectuer ce qui va être
belle important c'est de ne pas repartir
du site avec du virus donc plusieurs
mesures à mettre en place ce qu'on
manque s'est stationné le véhicule le
plus loin possible de la ferme première
chose
en débarquant du véhicule on met des
pentes off the table par dessus nos nos
pieds et on va s'approcher du bâtiment
comme ça
[Musique]
les experts font face à un ennemi
invisible dont le seul objectif est de
se trouver des cellules saines pour s'y
reproduire
il est capable de s'accrocher ou plus
fines particules et le virus aura
toujours un avantage sur l'éleveur son
ombre imaginez un individu qui excrète
de façon régulière des millions et des
millions de particules virales
donc c'est pratiquement impossible de
prendre à voir à sa surface
il ya des principes de barnes qu'on peut
pas échapper
il faut absolument utiliser ces
principes de base l'oeil de les
appliquer donc les mesures de
quarantaine
contrôler l'entrée les sorties que ça
soit l'eau la nourriture le matériel
agricole les animaux qui vont rentrer il
faut il faut vraiment contrôler qu'est
ce qui rend les caisses qui sortent pour
éviter toute contamination passé mais il
faut tout de même que le personnel
essentiel est accès au bâtiment
même en temps d'épidémie la depp a
convaincu les derniers éleveurs à doter
leur porcherie d'un aménagement bien
particulier
l'entrée danoise cet aménagement
s'avérera capitale pour freiner le virus
de la depp le précepte de l'entrée
danoise là c'est dur à croire que c'est
bien documenté scientifiquement c'est
vraiment à sa plus simple expression le
serbe est donc un candidat il ya un bain
qui empêche de continuer dans le
corridor du côté extérieur du bain on
laisse nos nos vêtements nos bottes on
s'assoit sur le banc sans que nos pieds
touchent partage de l'eau côté du bain
on met des bottes des vêtements de la
ferme on se lave les mains puis seul
c'est prouvé qu'en mettant 99% efficace
pour prévenir la transmission d'agents
partageant est à rentrer ou à sortir
dans une motion
[Musique]
c'est bien connu les virus cibles les
plus vulnérables
avant d'entrer au québec la dette avait
tué des millions de porcs aux états unis
des porcelets pour la plupart les jeunes
porcs ont peu d'immunité naturelle à
leur naissance
ce qui en fait des victimes parfaite
pour le virus
[Musique]
face à ce constat les producteurs
québécois ont répondu en rehaussant
leurs mesures sanitaires les douches par
exemple sont devenus obligatoires à
l'entrée de biens des maternités c'est
ce qu'on va mettre beaucoup l'emphase
sur protéger la plus possible et
maternité mais faut réaliser une chose
les maternités vont attraper le virus
m'a partir des porteurs asymptomatiques
les porteurs asymptomatiques c'est les
animaux adieu donc on peut peut-être
voir contrôler lille plus jeunes animaux
mais inévitablement ce qu'il est
contaminé les adultes donc faut aussi
virtuellement s'adresser aux adultes et
adressée en fait l'un fixe l'infection à
toutes les strates de la population
possède pas une strate 2
[Musique]
tôt ou tard un virus réussira malgré
tout à déjouer les barrières de
biosécurité en 2014
il aura fallu des mois de surveillance
et des milliers de tests pour détecter
l'arrivée du virus au québec c'est un
échantillon de fumier prélevés sur le
quai d'un abattoir qui a permis de
remonter la piste jusqu'à la ferme
infecté il en avance etats unis hausse
avec ça sans lien bret donc les abattons
québec avait pris l'initiative de
commencer à faire des tests sur les
quais de déchargement de façon
périodique
c'est comme ça que le premier cas a été
trouvée parce que les producteurs aient
pas vues sur des animaux plus âgés mais
symptômes sont beaucoup plus subtil
souvent ça passe inaperçu c'est lors
qu'il était à son très très très utile
sait détecter l'écho que les gens
savaient même pas qu'il y avait les
spécialistes de la santé animale sont
catégoriques
sans vaccin seules des mesures
sanitaires strictes ont permis
d'éradiquer le virus de la depp
même succès pour un autre coronavirus a
perdu quelques mois plus tard au québec
le delta record en un virus porcin
quelles leçons tirer de ces épidémies le
docteur françois cardinal envoie 2
la première c'est qu'il faut plus que
jamais rester vigilant à l'ère de la
mondialisation des transports et de
l'agriculture
les virus n'ont jamais aussi bien
voyager
il va en avoir d'autres dans ma courte
expérience en production porcine adapte
une maladie importante environ à toutes
les sapins la deuxième c'est que face à
des ennemis sournois il faut multiplier
les tests
c'est la clé du succès dans la lutte aux
épidémies toute maladie important qui a
réussi c'est quelque chose qui va
revenir est ce que c'est une possibilité
de tester de cette façon là pour
détecter l'écho a vaincu qui a eu une
masse critique trop importante qu'on ne
soit pas capable d'en venir à bout
chat soit trop difficile je pense que si
on n'avait pas fait de vitesse à
l'abattoir quant au top détection
précoce des cas oui il ya eu une
épidémie pas mal plus difficile à
contourner au québec
[Musique]
une